So we've all used our phones to send out text messages. But sometimes there is a
need for code to send texts. Consider the
following. Taxi companies send out text messages to
their passengers informing them of the cab driver's
location. Dating websites help potential couples communicate with
each other while using texts, but without sharing
phone numbers. To make authentication more secure Gmail sends
its users a security code via text message. This the Gmail user can
then use in addition to their
password. Retail organizations communicate daily deals to
their customers, while using texts. This use case seems important to a lot
of different companies, but what does it have to do with classes and objects?